What is it?
Look over there!
There really is a piano...
Of course! This is
the piano in the forest.
It's a piano!
I can't believe it!
With the light pouring through,
it looks like the forest is a stage!
It's even prettier at night.
Okay. You're my witness, okay?
You got it.
-It's broken.
-What?
No way. It makes sound.
But...
See?
-Try pressing the keys harder!
-There's no sound.
Let me try.
Just watch.It's never not made a sound!
See?
-Told ya.
-No way!
How?
Well, this is my piano after all.
I bet it only opens its heart for me.
Let me try again!
It's no use.
If I try any harder, I'll hurt my fingers.
All right, step aside.
That's the arrangement that
Mr. Ajino played yesterday.
Kai is amazing!
But... how?